what is going on everybody and welcome
to part 7 of our machine learning with
Python tutorial series in this video
we're going to be beginning to break
down linear regression and begin to
build it back up in pure Python code
from scratch ourselves before we get
started we have to kind of break down
linear regression theoretically before
we actually know what to to program by
the time we're done here you'll start to
at least understand one how linear
regression can be threaded but also most
importantly why it works with what's
known as continuous data this isn't just
a happenstance is just fundamental to
how this linear regression actually
works so let's go ahead and cover a
couple examples so for let's say you've
got a dataset expert visualization by
Centex like this okay
so when you look at these data points do
you see any sort of correlation well
probably you know you see a line that
goes something like that okay and let's
consider another data set and this data
set will do something like this not not
the most professional dots but you get
the point right so you can see how you
might draw a line through this right no
problem and in theory this should be a
straight line okay but then what about a
data set that looked like maybe a data
set that looks like this
ignoring this ugly plot over here right
this day set does it have a best-fit
line yes does have correlation not I
mean it probably has some sort of
correlation if anything that looks looks
like it has a slight negative
correlation but for the most part I mean
you could draw a best-fit line but would
it be a good fit line right any answer
of course is is is no okay so we can see
right away that you know is there a
relationship between in our case x and y
and it doesn't look like there is a
valid relationship between them
so in the case where you don't have a
relationship between x and y doing
something like linear regression is not
going to be very beneficial and also
it's just clearly that like yes X could
be in theory kind of continuous and Y
can be continuous data but we just see
there's no there's really no
relationship here okay so this data just
would not work with linear regression so
let's say though you do you've got a
graph and um you've got some data okay
so we've got some data and you decide
yeah you sure you sure can do linear
regression like like eyeballing it or
something we might say that okay so so
we have this line right this pink line
this is our best fit line right and it
is a we'll assume it's a straight line
what is the definition like how do you
define that line well I will take a
journey back to to middle school where
we remember that y equals MX plus B
right
and obviously we're you know you've got
your low values next to each other that
they're being multiplied so we know that
the equation of a line is y equals MX
plus B so at at any point along X right
like let's say you've got some X at any
point along X you would just you you
just plug X into here and then you need
the values of M and
be and then you will just get the answer
for whatever why is okay so with the
question of y equals MX plus B we know
that we'll be able to figure out
whatever X is but we are left trying to
figure out what is M and what is B so
first let's talk about what M is so we
know m is the slope alright so that's
the slope of the line and we know that B
is the y-intercept
okay so first let's consider the slope
so here we're going to just address M
which is our slope
so the equation for M is for a best-fit
we're talking about just for a best-fit
line here the way that you figure that
out is M equals and this is going to be
the mean of x times the mean of Y so
when you have a straight line those are
supposed to be straight lines we have a
straight line over the value that's just
that mean so X the mean of all the X's
times the mean of all the Y's minus the
mean of all the X's times the Y's ok so
it's important to understand the
difference between those first
multiplication that's 2nd multiplication
then it's all of that over the mean of
your X's squared minus the mean of your
X's squared right so this is the the
mean of all your X's to the power of 2
minus the mean of X's to the power of 2
right and that's all of your X's okay
now we're going to be talking about the
sum the y-intercept or the best-fit
y-intercept so that's just a B
eeee and that is your y-intercept I'm
just going to say why int and this one
is actually a much easier equation and
that is actually just simply B equals
and this is going to be the mean of the
Y's minus M times the mean of the XS
right so that M is you know from over
there so that's how you calculate the M
and the B so again the line is simply y
equals MX plus B we have our M here
we've got to be here so now you're ready
to go with the the calculation of the
best-fit line given any X's and Y's now
again this is simply on you know
two-dimensional data as you as you
increase in your dimensions in vector
space this can get much more complex but
yes whereas this is very simple
regression example so anyways that's the
math that goes behind it it just
basically boils down to you know this is
the major algorithm that you're using
and to find the values you're using this
algorithm in this algorithm and that can
be very simply translated to Python code
so that's what we're going to be
starting to do in the next tutorial is
converting these actually Python code
and then applying it to some actual some
actual data here so if you have any
questions comments concerns whatever
leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time